hi everybody
right back at you right back at you
and um obviously this is a very special
day
uh for me because i'm with my bestie
obviously
is everybody here are you guys with your
besties
yes
our besties the best
right
[Applause]
i shudder to think
where i would be without my bestie i
know and
california is very near and dear to our
hearts so this is a really amazing show
for us to do here in premiere week and i
will say this
um
now that i live in new york and whenever
i travel the country there's definitely
one thing
that i crave more than anything else i
mean all over the world you crave this
it's battle of the bites cali tacos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my goodness look at you oh my god i
just heard someone say taco and i showed
up
so let's do that do it
yes sir thank you
yes please
all right now we also have two viewers
and bffs joining our judging panel so
please welcome kelsey and malia
um okay since we're all besties you guys
are gonna count as one vote
and then we're all gonna vote as well we
also have a twitter vote happening so
the restaurant with the most votes will
take home a prize that'll give them
something to taco about
by the way
yeah i'm so proud of you
should we show the trophy everybody
all right well we each have three plates
of carne asada tacos in front of us
um and one is from mexicali taco and
company
hey
[Applause]
um they're a great place to uh jump off
rocks into water and stuff like that and
one taco from 1986
i'm dying
dying to know what happened to this
person in 1980
um all right up first is mahi cali taco
and company please take a look at this
little love letter for them hello drew
my name is jefferson
and i am the partner and chef here at
hikari taco and company and i'm so
excited for you to try to talk to us
today and we hope that you love them as
much as we do we started back in 2009
and we are proud to bring the northern
style tacos here to the city of los
angeles that's what really sets us apart
we specialize in flame broiled meats we
get an option of corn or flour tortilla
my favorite is a garnisa taco and flour
tortilla you put a little bit of salsa
it's got a little bit of a kick but it's
focused on fear of pure flavor and then
you get a little bit of avocado sauce
pickled red onions and fresh fresh
cabbage i love that mexican style taco
and i'm confident that you will too let
the best taco win
and estrus is in the audience joining us
hello
all right um anything we should keep in
our minds as we put this in our mouths
extra salsa
green or red what do you think
i'm going red
that
[Laughter]
these are
so delicious ross what do you think
you guys it's all about that heat and
then that uh tortilla i don't know what
magic you put in there but can i please
have the recipe the recipe i mean
delicious there's a yummy
texture to the tortilla that just brings
it all together that is
amazing thank you thank you
kelsey and malia thought
it just melts in your mouth i don't
wanna stop i'm gonna keep eating yeah
it's so it's so good it's delicious
thank you so very much your tacos are
incredible
and it is so hard to pry myself away
from them this is literally like this is
my dream job
like thank you best friend for bringing
me to this moment in my life to be a
taco a judge of tacos welcome okay
you're next okay i am next i'm okay
we're moving on to the next contender
sonora
town great place to jump across amazing
place to jump off rocks apparently
check this out
hi drew my name is jennifer feltham and
i'm the co-owner of sonora town in
downtown los angeles we're a northern
mexican style takada
my boyfriend tio moved here when he was
a young kid and couldn't find the style
of food that he grew up eating in san
luis rio colorado anywhere in los
angeles so that inspired us to open our
own place the name sonora town is taken
from a historic neighborhood in downtown
los angeles that existed here in the
1850s what makes our food unique we make
all of our own flour tortillas and house
we're making about 2 000 tortillas a day
we also bring in the best quality steak
because sonora is known for having the
best carne asada in all of mexico our
tacos are simple but delicious you get a
homemade flour tortilla freshly
barbecued carne asada spicy chiliado
salsa pureed avocado and cabbage
drew i'm so excited to be able to share
our family recipes with you today
jennifer is joining us in the audience
today
hi jennifer so excited to meet you guys
and share what we do with you all right
everybody okay here we go here we go
ready set bite okay around here
how incredibly different
your guys's style is completely like oh
my god
but
yum
yeah kelsey you had a big reaction what
was that all about that was a flavor
explosion in my mouth
it was so delicious all the textures in
that cream is that the avocado there's
no cream in it it's just pureed avocado
but you get that sensation that's
amazing so yummy rossy thoughts i am
obsessed with this taco it is so good it
is salty and spicy but there is such
freshness that just pops through well
done
and clearly i love your home
i'll see you at the restaurant i'll see
you on the rock okay perfect yes
all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break but coming up we have
one more taco to try
and then we're gonna declare our winner
[Music]
[Applause]
cali tacos now this is our besties hour
so kelsey and malia are also over there
joining us because they're besties
by the way how long have you been
besties
six years since we moved to la at the
same time to dance well we have been
enjoying tacos we've already tried
mexicali taco and company and sonora
town and our final contender is taco's
1984
hi drew my name is jorge alvarez tostado
people call me elle joy i'm one of the
doctors and owners here at tacos 1986.
we started off as a taco stand november
2018 on the corner of highland and
lexington and hollywood and now we have
five amazing stores
this taqueria was inspired by a tijuana
style taco which is where me and my
partner victor are from what makes our
taco unique it's our handmade tortilla
that's followed by your choice of
protein our carne salad taco starts with
a handmade tortilla grilled steak
garnish with onion cilantro guacamole
and salsa i'm the greatest taker of all
time bring on the competition
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody what happened in 1986. that's
the year i was born
i'm pretty
all right
hold up hold up you have to put the
salsas that are right next to that plate
right there it could be uh the green
salsa or the straw that's a chili salsa
is that the hotter one yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah throw it in it and uh that one
right there the strawberry salsa this
one that one right there the hottest
what is this
[Laughter]
thought i think the
texture of the tortilla is really nice
and there's a lot of brightness in it
even though it feels like very
comforting and homey rossi
i don't want this taco to never ever end
yeah this is so good all right i just
want to say to each and every one of you
thank you for this ribbon
growing up in california you know we
take tacos for granite because they're
everywhere and um we it's really about
the culture
that we share in california southern
california in particular with mexico our
neighbors and we have to remember that
that food like really has been such a
big part of all of our lives and we
wouldn't have it without that culture
without that country and i really just
appreciate that culture
it is time to vote but i think um before
we do uh let's reveal
who our twitter poll
um
chose because we asked you all to vote
on your favorite and the winning taco
with 47 percent
was tacos 1986
i love it now it is our turn and um i am
going to start it off
[Music]
and
it kills me to say it because i love
them all but i'm going to i'm going to
put this front and center
okay i'm gonna go for
[Applause]
um all right ross all of these tacos
were delicious and i want to thank you
all for turning our daytime talk show
into a daytime taco show
there can only be one winner and i have
to vote for
[Applause]
um all right kelsey and malia are you
ready kelsey let's do it
[Music]
i mean
we've actually
gotten ourselves into a thai situation
yeah all right so um guess what uh both
of these restaurants are going to get a
trophy
congratulations to all three restaurants
and thank you kelsey and malia you guys
are so awesome
[Applause]
[Music]